throughout Portugal's rise from small
nation to global imperial power it had a
monarchy from a Fonz at the first whose
name definitely didn't have an L in it
to Manuel ii the king of portugal was a
well respected title yet nowadays
portugal is a republic in a proud one at
that but why what happened to the
Portuguese monarchy
so as of 1889 the Portuguese monarchy
hit a bit of an image problem Portugal
was seen as a declining nation despite a
gaining some brand new imperial
territory in Africa and much of this was
blamed on the monarchy much of this was
down to the king at this point louis the
first in his appointment of governments
which were essentially the same thing
the prime ministers were the king's
friends and so they did as he asked but
their parties had different names and
said they were totally different these
problems had seen the rise of
anti-monarchist sentiment along with the
creation of small and illegal republican
parties in 1890 this idea of a declining
nation that by a useless corrupt king
was made worse when the portuguese
received a message from their closest
friends the British whom the Portuguese
had been allies with since 1373 and thus
it could only be good news just kidding
the message was an ultimatum and it
demanded the Portugal withdrawal from
some of its lands in Africa and
acknowledged that they in fact belonged
to Britain and Carlos the first and his
government promptly folded to the
British demands and the main reason was
that Portugal was reliant on British
loans and investments in response to
this the Portuguese people were to put
it mildly quite upset so upset at this
national humiliation that the next year
there was a Republican revolution in
Porto this republican revolt was put
down quickly but the revolutions leaders
did something important they made sure
that progress was linked with
republicanism in the popular
consciousness the continuation of these
policies by the Portuguese government
led to many people leaving the country
in Portugal as well falling further and
further behind the rest of Europe as the
19th century came to a close despite a
ban on the portuguese republican party
from running in elections the party's
popularity continued to grow most of
this was down to the fact that the
monarchy served as a figurehead for the
country's numerous issues which over the
following 17 years the government is
little about things changed in 1908 when
King Carlos and his son Prince Louie
Philippe were assassinated the throne
passed to his eldest surviving son
Manuel ii who initially made some
concessions to his critics however it
was mostly too little too late and he
also made one mistake in the eyes of
portuguese reformers he maintained
strong relation
with the united kingdom who were largely
seen by the portuguese population as
having taken advantage of a week in
portugal and using it for its own profit
portugal was in the following two years
of volatile place and things soon
descended into political violence which
culminated in the revolution of 1910
they saw the military side with the
Republicans and decide to ask the king
who promptly fed for Britain the
Portuguese Republic was declared soon
after and it was frankly a hot mess of a
political system since it turns out that
things don't get magically fixed by
ousting the guy with the crown there
were numerous attempts at counter cooze
to restore the monarchy and none of them
really had any popular support and so
they failed in fact Manuel who remained
a phase portuguese patriots until his
death in 1932 condemned any attempts of
violence to restore the monarchy after
this there was little appetite to
restore the monarchy since much like
getting rid of it in the first place
restoring it likely wouldn't have
changed much was Portugal's embrace of
republicanism can sometimes be seen as a
relatively new thing it's important to
note that in terms of overthrowing Roy
was permanently Portugal was the third
European country to do so I hope you
enjoyed this episode and thank you for
watching with the special thanks to my
patrons James Bissonnette John lucid a
man of culture Danny Maloney little
holiday John biscuits Rob Waterhouse mo
James Castaneda Aaron the white Jordan
Longley Gustav Swan Markus asana rashid
ali spinning three plates filled oink
oink david silverman maggie packs Kowski
spencer Lightfoot Lexi Schwinn Kelly
moneymaker
Anthony Beckett Robert Wetzel Skye
Chappell Marvin Castle
Winston Hayward and Izzy